Here's our answer. Great algebra skills if you found that one out. First we
distribute our negative sign to each term in our numerator. So we'll have plus
negative two b plus five. Make sure you change that sign there. Next we find the
lowest common denominator, which is b plus two, times b minus two, times b plus
five. Next we multiply each fraction by a form of one. This denominator was
missing b plus 5, and this denominator was missing b plus 2. Next we multiply
these two numerators together, to get b squared plus 8b plus 15. For the second
equivalent fraction, we'll multiply negative 2b plus 5, times b plus 2. This
gives us this trinomial, and finally we add the like terms of each numerator
together. B squared and negative 2b squared equals negative 1b squared. 8b and
positive b equal 9b and 15 and 10 equal 25. So this is our final answer. We also
know that this is our final answer because we can't factor this enumerator
further. There are no factors of negative 25. That's sum to positive nine. I
hope you've gained a lot of practice with adding and subtracting rational
expressions.